many of the victims of Monday's volcanic
eruption in New Zealand were passengers
from a well Caribbean cruise ship Royal
Caribbean tells CBS News it is now
suspending tours of active volcanoes
earlier the company said it was
devastated by the tragedy this incident
is raising questions for all cruise line
operators about their liability and the
excursion providers that do business
with them CBS is warning consumer
investigative correspondent and a Warner
is with us Anna that seems to be an
issue that a lot of people should be
taking a look at yeah and I don't think
most horas really pay a lot of attention
to this but it is good to know what
risks you may be taking assigning blame
winning damages when injuries occur
that's pretty complicated because not
only is there usually more than one
company involved but more than one
country as well often times there are
measures however you can take to protect
yourself 47 people nine of them
Americans were near New Zealand's white
island volcano when it erupted most of
them part of a day-trip excursion
offered to passengers CBS News travel
editor Peter Greenberg the people who
bought these excursions bought them
through the cruise company then the
cruise company outsourced it to an
outside vendor but the question remains
should the vendor have canceled this
excursion in the weeks leading up to the
eruption geonet which tracks hazard
information in New Zealand warned new
volcanic activity on white island meant
an imminent eruption was possible but
said the week before the eruption that
geological activity did not pose a
direct hazard to visitors it's likely
everyone on the excursion signed a
liability waiver that's true for the
estimated 7,000 excursions an expert
tells us are offered annually by cruise
lines everything from zip lines to scuba
diving to bungee jumping Sania waiver
doesn't necessarily mean the vendors
protected you still may have rights the
eruption is far from the only deadly
excursion from a cruise ship back in May
six passengers aboard the Royal Princess
were killed while on an aerial
sightseeing excursion over Alaska's
Misty Fjords National Monument when the
two planes they were in
collided in midair and in December of
2017 12 people were killed and 18
injured in a bus crash during a land
excursion from two Royal Caribbean
cruises in Mexico despite any potential
dangers for many passengers shore
excursions are an essential part of a
cruise vacation travelers today want a
more immersive experience they want to
be able to get there up close and
personal and they're more than willing
to sign those waivers because it's one
of their bucket list as for the victims
of the eruption on white island who want
to hold someone responsible due to a 45
year old law in New Zealand the
excursion company may be legally
protected from being sued it's basically
a no-fault insurance plan where nobody
gets to sue and nobody has blamed they
can just get a payout from the
government or from an insurance fund
however the payout is limited it's about
two hundred thousand New Zealand dollars
at the top end so that's just over a
hundred and thirty two thousand dollars
in u.s. dollars we've reached out to
Princess Cruises and Royal Caribbean
about any litigation connected to their
previous excursion accidents but they
have not responded so it's time so what
our folks do who take these dispersions
what how do they protect themselves so
one of the thing to keep keep in mind if
you're going on a foreign trip is you
might want to get something called
medical evacuation and repatriation
insurance that protects you of you
become sick or injured while you're
overseas some of these places you want
to have medical evacuation and it's
worth the money to pay that so that
somebody will come get you and take you
to a hospital that can really treat you
if there's something seriously wrong
with you because depending on what
country you're in now to Zealand would
have great hospitals but some countries
don't really have the hospital systems
comparative to the u.s. that you may
expect to have so you're gonna want that
insurance think about that two stories
we've done now that will require that
the guy in Mexico at the hospital I will
say I still have cruise ships to get on
the ocean we will be going on one soon
thank you very much